so okay
so stanford how'd you get into
autonomous vehicles i
had the great fortune and
great honor to join stanford's darpa
urban challenge team
in 2006 there this was a third in the
sequence of the
darpa challenges there were two grand
challenges
prior to that and then in 2007 they held
the darpa urban challenge
so you know i was doing my postdoc i had
i joined
the team and uh worked
on motion planning uh for you know
that that competition so okay so for
people who might not know
i know from from a certain person
autonomous vehicles is a funny world
in a certain circle of people everybody
knows everything and then a certain
circle
uh nobody knows anything in terms of
general public so it's interesting
it's it's a good question what to talk
about but
i do think that the urban challenge is
worth revisiting it's a fun little
challenge
one that first like sparked so much
so many incredible minds to focus on one
of the hardest problems
of our time in artificial intelligence
so that's it's a success from a
perspective of a single little challenge
but can you talk about like what did the
challenge involve
so were there pedestrians were there
other cars
what was the goal uh who was on the team
how long did it take any fun fun sort of
specs sure so the way the
the challenge was constructed in just a
little bit of background and as i
mentioned this was the
third uh competition in that series the
first two
were the grand challenge called the
grand challenge the goal there was to
just
drive in a completely static environment
you know you had to drive in the desert
uh that was very successful so then
darpa followed
with what they called the urban
challenge where the goal was to have you
know build vehicles that could
operate in more dynamic environments and
share them with other vehicles there
were no pedestrians
there but what darpa did is they took
over an abandoned
air force base and it was kind of like a
little fake city
that they built out there and they had
a bunch of uh robots uh you know cars
that were autonomous in there all at the
same time uh
mixed in with other vehicles driven by
professional
uh drivers and each car had a mission
and so there's a crude map that they
received
at the beginning and they had a mission
you go you know here and then there and
over here
and they kind of all were sharing this
environment at the same time they
interact to interact with each other
they had to interact with the human
drivers
there's this very first very rudimentary
um
version of a self-driving car that
you know could operate uh and on yeah in
an environment you know shared with
other dynamic actors
that as you said you know really you
know many ways
you know kick started this whole
industry okay so
who was on the team and how did you do i
forget
uh we came in second uh
perhaps that was my contribution to the
team i think the stanford team came in
first in the darpa challenge
but then i joined the team and you know
you were the one with the bug in the
code i mean do you have sort of memories
of some particularly challenging things
or you know one of the cool things it's
not a
you know this isn't a product this isn't
the thing that uh
you know if there's you have a little
bit more freedom to experiment so you
can take risks and there's
uh so you can make mistakes uh so is
there interesting mistakes
is there interesting challenges that
stand out to you or some like taught you
um a good technical lesson or a good
philosophical lesson
from that time yeah uh you know
definitely definitely a very
memorable time not really a challenge
but like one of the
most vivid memories that i have from the
time
and i think that was actually one of the
days that
really got me hooked uh on this whole
field was
the first time i got to run my software
on the car and i was working on a part
of
our planning algorithm that had to
navigate in parking lots so
something that you know called free
space motion planning so the very first
version of that
we tried on the car it was on stanford's
campus uh
in the middle of the night and you know
i had this little you know course
constructed with cones
uh in the middle of a parking lot so
we're there like 3 a.m you know by the
time we got the code to
you know uh you know compile and turn
over
and you know it drove like it actually
did something quite reasonable
and you know it was of course very buggy
at the time
and had all kinds of problems but it was
pretty darn magical i remember going
back
and you know you know late at night
trying to fall asleep and just you know
being unable to fall asleep for
you know the rest of the night uh just
my mind was blown
and yeah that that that's what i've been
you know doing ever since
for more than a decade uh in terms of
challenges and
uh you know interesting memories like on
the day of the competition i it was
being pretty
nerve-wracking uh i remember standing
there with mike montemerla who was
uh the software elite and wrote most of
the code like i did one little part of
the planner mike
you know incredibly that you know pretty
much the rest of it uh with with you
know
a bunch of other incredible people but i
remember standing on the day of the
competition
uh you know watching the car you know
with mike and your cars are
completely empty right they're all there
lined up in the beginning of the race
and then you know darpa sends them you
know on their mission one by one
so then leave and like you just they had
these sirens
they all had their different silence
silence right each siren had its own
personality if you will so you know off
they go and you don't see them you just
kind of and then every once in a while
they you know come a little bit closer
to where
uh the audience is and you can kind of
hear you know the sound of your car
and you know it seems to be moving along
so that you know gives you hope and then
you know
it goes away and you can't hear it for
too long you start getting anxious right
just a little bit like you know sending
your kids to college and like you know
kind of you invested in them you hope
you you you you build it properly but
like it's still anxiety-inducing uh so
that was
an incredibly uh fun few days
in terms of you know bugs as we
mentioned you know one
that was my bug that caused us the loss
of the first place
is still a debate that you occasionally
have with people on the cmu team cmu
came first
i should mention uh that you haven't
heard of them
but yeah no it's something you know it's
a small school it's it's it's
really a glitch that you know they
happen to succeed at something robotics
related very scenic though
most people go there for the scenery um
yeah
it's a beautiful campus
unlike stanford so for people yeah
that's true i like stanford for people
who don't know cmu is one of the great
robotics and sort of artificial
intelligence
universities in the world cmu carnegie
mellon university
okay sorry go ahead good good psa so in
the part that i
contributed to which was navigating
parking lots and the way
you know that part of the mission worked
is
yeah you in a parking lot you would get
from darpa
an outline of the map you can get this
you know giant polygon
that defined the perimeter of the
parking lot uh and there would be an
entrance and you know maybe
multiple entries or access to it and
then you would get a goal
within that open space uh xy
you know heading where the car had to
park it had no information about the
optical
obstacles that the car might encounter
there so it had to navigate
kind of completely free space from the
entrance to the parking lot
into that parking space and then
uh once you're parked there it had to
exit the parking lot while of course
encountering and reasoning about all the
obstacles that it encounters in real
time so
uh our interpretation or at least my
interpretation of the rules was that you
had to reverse
out of the parking spot and that's what
our cars did even if there's no
optical in front that's not what seem
used car did and it just kind of
drove right through so there's still a
debate and of course you know if you
stop and then reverse out and go out the
different way
that costs you some time right so
there's still a debate
whether you know it was my poor
implementation that cost us extra time
or whether it was
you know cmu uh violating an important
rule of the competition and you know i
have my own
uh opinion here in terms of other bugs
and like i i have to apologize to mike
montemerla
for sharing this on air but it is
actually
one of the more memorable ones uh and
it's something that's
kind of become a bit of a a metaphor and
a label in the industry
since then i think at least in some
circles it's called the victory circle
or victory lap
um and uh our cars did that
so in one of the missions in the urban
challenge
and one of the courses uh there was this
big oval right
by the start and finish of the race so
darpa had
a lot of the missions would finish kind
of in that same location uh and it was
pretty cool because you could see the
cars come by you know kind of finish
that part lag of the trip they'll have
that leg of the mission and then you
know go on
and finished the rest of it uh
and other vehicles would you know come
hit their waypoint uh and you know exit
the oval and
off they would go our car in the hand
which hit the checkpoint
and then it would do an extra lap around
the awful and only then
you know uh leave and go on its merry
way so over the course of you know the
full day it accumulated uh
uh some extra time and the problem was
that we had a bug where it wouldn't you
know start reasoning about the next
waypoint and plan a route to get to that
next point until it hit the previous one
and in that particular case by the time
you hit
the that that one it was too late for us
to consider the next one and kind of
make a lane change so that every time it
would do like an extra lap so
known as the the stanford victory lap
the victory
oh there's there's i feel like there's
something philosophically profound in
there somehow but uh
i mean ultimately everybody is a winner
in that kind of competition
and it led to sort of famously to the
creation of
google self-driving car project and now
waymo
you